qué tal Muy buenas tardes Rodrigo Pues
el Centro Nacional de Huracanes ha
confirmado efectivamente que hace menos
de una hora que el huracán Ian ha tocado
tierra y lo ha hecho en Cayo Costa muy
cerca de las ciudades de Sarasota y de
Fort Myers hasta el momento se desconoce
el alcance que podría tener este paso
del huracán por esta zona la costa oeste
de la Península de la Florida pero se
sabe que lo ha hecho con muchísima
violencia Con vientos de más de 240
kilómetros por hora muy cercanos a la
categoría 5 según hemos podido comprobar
a través de las imágenes que se han
empezado a difundir a través de las
redes sociales hemos visto pues fuertes
inundaciones provocadas también por esas
lluvias que ha dejado el huracán Ian los
pronósticos avisaban que se iban a
registrar un aumento del nivel del mar
de más de Tres metros más de 800.000
personas se han quedado hasta el momento
sin luz y los equipos de emergencia ni
siquiera pueden salir a efectuar en
ningún tipo de operativo porque podría
poner en peligro sus vidas las
autoridades de Florida piden a toda la
población seguir manteniéndose en un
lugar seguro algunas ciudades incluso de
la costa oeste de Florida han decretado
el toque de queda incluso para después
de que termine esta tormenta sobre todo
porque podría ser muy peligroso porque
el tendido eléctrico podría estar en
contacto con el agua y eso podría poner
en peligro también a la población